hey guys welcome back to my youtube
channel I am Pat Metheny your yoga
teacher for the day
this is Simba of course who has decided
to join us today so today as promised I
filmed for you a tutorial for free flow
so we're gonna chat for a minute first
and then I thought that we could kind of
you could get your mats out and we could
practice all at the same time but it
won't be like a guided tutorial like all
of my others and I'm gonna talk you
through how I structure a free flow and
then we're going to kind of probably
work through it hopefully together so
just one thing to note is that when you
sequence your own practice when you kind
of just flow with the body that does
come in time and it comes with them
slightly more I guess advanced practice
and I don't mean advance in terms of you
can do all of the more advanced postures
by advance I just mean that you have an
understanding of both your body and the
practice and maybe you already know
sequences like your Surya Namaskar A's
and B's so your Sun Salutations so
that's gonna be a really really great
place to start and I actually start all
of my free flows all of my self practice
my home practice I will start in the
color in the same way so I have a
structure sometimes and to my practice
if I know that I'm gonna be practicing
and I want it to be sort of 45 minutes
to an hour maybe a little bit longer
then I will have a little bit of a
structure whereby I work with my
meditation then my pranayama so my
breathing control then I'll move on to a
warm-up working through some cat and cow
and things like that testing out my
downward-facing dog things like that
then I'll move on to my Sun Salutations
now by this point I am nice and warm and
I've worked into the body I've worked
through a little bit of stretching I've
worked on strength I've built up a
little bit heat in the body after I've
done my Sun Salutations I'll move on to
some Stan
postures so that could be anything and
sometimes obviously it'll be fancier
than other times sometimes I will quite
literally just work through a bit of a
warrior sequence and that will be kind
of from warrior one warrior to take a
reverse warrior come through humble
warrior push up into warrior three and
like a warrior flow is really really
strong and that's just a really nice
kind of slightly more simple one to work
with and just holding for sort of three
to five breaths so obviously there are
many ways and feelings into the body now
if this is my early morning practice
maybe you can tell ya got yesterday's
braids in and that's okay so for me
today I'm probably gonna take quite a
slow warmup but maybe if I was doing my
practice in the evening I've kind of
worked into it a little bit quicker
because my body might be a bit warmer so
these are all things that you need to
look at when you come to find that
grounding and that present kind of
feeling within the body before you
practice now before we get started I
want to talk a little bit about kind of
the Instagram world of yoga just because
it's really important now for me
sometimes when I will put up a flow and
it will be a free flow and it will just
be me moving around my mat and it will
be sped up now you want to remember that
that was probably maybe just five to ten
minutes of my practice that I've been
squished down into one minute and my
whole one hour practice will not
necessarily be like that so a lot of the
time myself included my Sun Salutations
would have come first my warmup will
have come first and then we move on to
the things that make me challenge us a
little bit more the things that are a
bit more dynamic now when I work through
things like when you met you maybe if
you follow me on instagram you'll have
seen some of my flows and I'll come
through three-leg dog and then wild
thing and then thread the leg through
and then all of this and it's all this
kind of one breath one action and sort
of feeling now that is tiring on the
body and that isn't the way I would flow
for sort of half an hour to an hour
that's the way I flow for maybe five to
ten minutes and then I cool it
down and work on some stretches so it's
just really important that we know that
we're not necessarily that what you see
on Instagram isn't necessarily what
you're going to be doing today maybe it
will be for you because this is going to
be very much your practice like I say
this is going to become easier in time
when you have a deeper understanding of
the practice and of your own body so to
begin with I think that we're all gonna
start together okay so we'll just come
down to a comfortable seated position
this is how I will start every single
practice close off my eyes and I'll just
take a big circle back with my shoulders
and now here's the time where I kind of
tap into how the body's feeling so I
just take a bit of a body scan I'm
thinking to myself hmm okay and it is
feeling good have been out for a walk
this morning I want to kind of work in
slightly more of that dynamic way but
I'm feeling that my chest needs to be
opened that's what I'm feeling right now
is that I'm a little bit kind of curved
in my shoulders I really want to open
out so that's probably where I'm gonna
go for my my opening for my warmup we're
all different remember and then here at
the start is where ice happens my breath
as well so first of all if I'm gonna be
doing some pranayama then I might take
the hands to the belly now a really
simple one that we could just do
together now is an inhale for four and
an exhale for four and we'll just repeat
that maybe you want to go into some
humming breath maybe you want to do some
Breath of Fire maybe some equal some
nostril breathing so whatever it is that
you do and obviously don't be scared
when I say things like that and you're
like I don't know what she's talking
about because like I said that comes in
time so let's just keep it simple we'll
just take some nice big inhale through
the nose out through the nose in for
four out for four take a big inhale to
begin with
then it'll allow
and then we'll inhale one two three four
exhale one two three four I'll let you
count that on your own now while I do
mine maybe you want to bring it out to
six maybe you want to bring out to eight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe you want to set an intention for
your practice
the breath come back to its natural
rhythm
[Music]
and then just start to warm up the body
so obviously I will be assuming that
there aren't any newbies to beginners
coming to this video because you're
gonna need to have a bit of an
understanding of just how to stretch out
the body at least so if you are a
beginner than I'll recommend doing maybe
some of my other videos but the rest of
us just starts with maybe warm up the
body you can start always working from
the head all the way down to the feet or
the opposite way around whatever works
for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so they're using your warm up to just
work into every part of the body
especially the parts that you maybe sort
of felt needed a little bit of openings
for our grounding
[Music]
I usually find like a nice
downward-facing dog at some point in my
warmup as well just to pedal out through
the feet and do things like that
[Music]
obviously as well taking just the
modified variations of postures when you
need them maybe challenging yourself a
little bit with postures
[Music]
so now sort of coming to the end of your
warmup however that might be if you need
to take longer of course you can
remember this is your practice
we just free-flowing at the same time
with me on camera but now's the time
where I'll go through my Sun Salutations
taking some time to energize the body
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so for me now that's two Sundays to some
bees and after my son sanitation's I can
normally then get a feel for how the
rest of my flow is gonna go so for me
today early morning I had a long weekend
I'm feeling like I really just want to
stretch deeply into my body I've done
the energizing through my Sun
Salutations and my body doesn't want to
take here any more dynamic than that now
maybe yours does so maybe you're gonna
work through something a little bit
different but for me I'm just gonna take
some kind of nice long deep stretches
because that's where I want to go so I'm
just going to talk you through so if
right now I'm gonna take a left leg back
I'm gonna come down to a low lunge okay
so I'm in my low lunge there's lots of
places that I can go from here so from
here I can come back to a half split I
can work back and I can do one breath
one action remember that you've got two
kind of sections of body but your lower
body and your upper body so maybe you
want my lower body
is in a lunge I want to take up just
move my knee I want to take a twist with
my upper body or maybe I want to take a
backbend
so these are all things to think about
when you're doing your free flow you
want to really be able to work through
things and Link things in a way that
feels good for your body now I know and
this is because obviously I know
postures so the like I say comes in time
I know that I can come back to a half
split this feels great I might come
forward and then I want to open out so
you make glutes and my IT band so I'm
going to take my right arm over the top
and open out here
[Music]
then if I want to continue this stretch
in this sort of stretch but in a
different posture I'm going to come
around to seated and forward fold so the
important thing with free flow is not to
worry about where you are on the map
it's almost sometimes quite nice not to
have a mat because I know that we'd like
the map because they're grippy and
everything but then it allows us just to
kind of move freely and not worry about
front and back and left and right too
much yes we want to keep the body in in
some kind of balance so we want to
repeat sides but it's really important
that we just kind of feel that freedom
so kind of find your middle section as
it were so maybe you're gonna work
through some standing postures because
you're feeling strong maybe even
throwing some kind of like power bits
and pieces like core work and stuff like
that or maybe you're gonna feel like a
bit more stretchy like I am today
so yeah just kind of like find where you
are at
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
just remember as well that there is no
kind of right or wrong with your free
flow so wherever it is that you're
working obviously I gave you the
structure of kind of the warmup
sanitation's they hut the up the down
finish but ultimately if you want to go
up down and all around because that's
where your body fancies and you want to
have fun with it then by all means
go for it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and also just remember as well that free
flow is awesome but you do tend to go
where always feels good so for me lower
body hits always feels great it's quite
rare although I do do it because I know
that I have to but it is quite rare that
I will free flow into a deep backbend
session like I say I do do it but not as
often as I work through my lower body so
it's just that's why I guided staff and
tutorials and real classes are amazing
because they make us work through our
resistances
[Music]
and sometimes you might notice that
you've missed out a posture like that
has and that's fine
just come back to it
at anytime
the beauty of it being your own practice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't forget that you can use what
you've got around you so be that trumps
or the rule anything like that
[Music]
[Music]
you make the rules with your free flow
don't forget that so as much as of
course alignment and technique are
really important you make the wrong
rules you flow for as long as you want
you finish whenever you're ready and you
keep going for as long as you fancy
that's the beauty of it but you do need
to have that kind of self motivation so
it can be kind of hard and it happens to
me sometimes I'll be you know half an
hour into the flow with all my
intentions that start being to practice
for an hour and then I'll just be like
yeah I'm ready just to lay on my mat
mount a cashew fastness so yeah it's
just kind of having that motivation
maybe just putting on an album and
knowing that that album is 45 minutes
long and you've got a nice song at the
end to relax to those sort of things are
nice ways to kind of time your practice
or to kind of the F get into the groove
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then maybe you're ready at some
point to kind of comment you're
finishing a little sequence so depending
on what style of yogurt you do in
vinyasa we have a few kind of different
ways I mean there's more of a
traditional finishing sequence whereby
you'll come through shoulder stand
plow pose air pressure pose fish
matsyasana to can't pose rock all the
way up your look may be done some back
bends before that rock up takes your
breath and then come down to your
shavasana
maybe I normally basically finish with
either a shoulder stand an inversion a
back bend or if I'm not feeling any of
those things I'll just take my bottom
but maybe I'll take a supportive bridge
or I'll just take my bottom on the block
with my legs up in the air so they're
all kind of ways with your kind of free
flow if you don't want to follow a
tutorial so kind of slowly work into
kind of things that don't feel normal
and it's really good as well like I
think that we see things especially on
Instagram whereby like every flow is
different and so creative but it is
really important to repeat things so
your body gets used to things you work
on the same things you get better at
them you understand your body more while
you're in the postures so that's why I
always do my son sanitation
and that's why I'll kind of always come
through kind of a similar maybe closing
sequence or something like that for me
today I'm feeling like I said like I
just want to chill out so I'm gonna take
a nice supportive bridge and close off
my eyes maybe you've got a little bit
longer to practice that's totally cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna make my way to a little
relaxation I'm not gonna stay too long
my home practice my shavasana is
something I need to spend more time on
but it's very very tempting always just
to kind of get up and get going but it's
so important so even if you just lay for
like thirty Seconds to a minute
make sure you have that time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I really hope that you enjoyed that
maybe some of you are sort of stretching
maybe somebody was still in your
shavasana if that's the case I will just
talk for a little bit and then leave you
be to enjoy your practice so like I said
hopefully you enjoyed that and I hope
you feel proud of yourself you were able
to kind of like work into the body now
maybe for some of you you found yourself
kind of looking at what I was doing
maybe copying what I was doing and you
know it takes time it's not the kind of
practice that comes instantly and like I
said it's gonna come with kind of
knowledge of postures knowledge of
alignment I have a dance background so
naturally it's quite it comes naturally
to me to be able to link things and flow
through things so I kind of hold a
little bit of an advantage there but
what's really nice is if maybe the next
time you come to your mat you work
through your Sun Salutation so that's a
great practice to learn first so if
you're here and you didn't even really
know the Sun Salutation sequence I would
say kind of get that down have that kind
of in your bank and then that's where
you move on from and then once you've
got that there are loads of books and
there are apps with yoga postures and
things like that and once you've done
that maybe you could just have your book
or have your app next to you and you
could just kind of like see how it feels
to link postures be like I'll hold on
does this one work does that one work
you know so for example maybe you found
yourself in an ardha matsyendrasana and
you were in this twist and maybe kind of
naturally like you would think okay I'll
just untwist I'll go to the other side
I'll come back I'll do maybe another
seating posture why not think about
where what what other ways the body can
go from this twist
so the body could go all the way behind
you and you could step out and do a
vinyasa the body could come over onto
one hand you could stretch out that leg
and take a nice big side stretch so
there's loads of ways in which we can
link and transition posture to posture
and it just comes with time so please do
of course comment below with any
questions I would do my best
answer them and hopefully you've enjoyed
that and you've been able to take away a
little bit of knowledge now obviously I
gave you a kind of idea of a structure
that kind of helps when you're new to
your free flow but as you kind of get
into the body a little bit more you will
you will kind of lose the structure in a
little bit maybe you'll keep it like I
will always kind of start with some
sanitation's if I'm working in the
morning into energy obviously from doing
more of a restorative practice then that
I won't so there are so many different
styles and ways of moving and flowing on
your yoga mat that there's kind of a no
one-size-fits-all as we know with many
different things so it's just about kind
of finding what works for you and that
will change day by day with yoga and so
for me today it was all about stretching
for me tomorrow it might all be about
power and working into the core so we
just have to kind of like take it as we
get as we kind of see it as we feel it
in the body and yeah work through it
that way but thank you so much for
joining me I hope that you enjoyed that
and I will see you on Sunday for another
yoga flow bye bye